the idea phase that is how you go from
the idea phase to actually building out
the first version of your product and if
you're not familiar with with tote
we've been dubbed the Netflix for
fashion so we provide unlimited access
to our closet of women's apparel and
accessories for a fixed price each month
and the business is going really well
we've been growing like crazy whoa
we've been growing like crazy we've got
over 200 employees today split between
two locations and we've raised it over
30 million dollars from top tier VCS
like Google Ventures andreessen horowitz
and Y Combinator so we're gonna talk
about getting started today and the only
thing that really matters when you're
starting your business is getting to
products market fit this is gonna be
interesting so product market fit is
basically putting something out there
that really strikes a nerve with
consumers something that people are
really excited about and for us what
that meant or how we got started getting
towards product market fit was my
co-founders wife was pregnant and she
realized that buying maternity clothes
is insane you only use them for four or
five months and then you never see them
again and at the same time my wife was
in a clothing swap group in the city and
she was constantly looking for more
variety in her closet and we were all
out to dinner one night we got to
talking and realized that both of these
women were doing the exact same thing to
get access to variety and we thought to
ourselves
would it be interesting if you took this
online and gave people unlimited access
to a closet that they could all use so
we started talking to more people over
the coming weeks and the idea started
seeming better and better but the big
question that we had to ask ourselves
was are we willing to quit our cushy
finance jobs and go all-in on this idea
well needless to say a couple weeks
later we quit our jobs and well and we
took over the kids playroom so this is
our very first office we've got a sweet
basketball hoop here we had a fold-out
couch which was helpful for late nights
and we put up a white board and we
poured our collective savings into the
business and started buying clothing and
accessories and I can't tell you guys
how many times I got a fraud alert phone
call from Wells Fargo saying hey Bret
did you just buy seven thousand dollars
worth of women's dresses and
frighteningly the answer was yes
every single time but we didn't really
care because in the early days you're
just trying to figure out if people want
what you're putting out into the world
so we were trying to answer fundamental
questions about our business like how
many times can you send out a dress
before it starts getting worn out and
how much does it cost to ship these
items all over the country and even
something as simple as do people want
unlimited fashion on a rental model so
another piece of advice I have early on
is you've got to have someone by your
side to help out so for me I had a
co-founder but it was a lot more than
that you've got to have someone in the
trenches you can bounce ideas off of
someone who's there to pick you up when
you're feeling unmotivated and it wasn't
just my co-founder it was a family
affair for us from day one so this is
actually a picture of my co-founders
wife and his newborn daughter and they
were helping us unbag one of our first
inventory buys and it didn't stop there
so we also convinced a good friend of
ours who was a buyer out in New York
City to pack up her life fly to San
Francisco sleep on one of our couches
for six months and help us get this
crazy idea off the ground and my
co-founders parents even got involved so
they came to visit from India and they
thought they were gonna have a relaxing
three months visit and gets to the
family well we convinced them to come to
the office every single day and do
administrative tasks around the office
this is very serious by the way they
totally made all of these boxes so I
stressed this point because it
really critical early on to get people
to help you out to bring your product to
life is this really hard and it's an
uphill battle and you hear no all the
time so you need that support system
there and just know that things will
break in the early days so you're
optimizing for speed over perfection and
these are actually racks that I built
myself so as you can tell I'm a really
shitty handyman but the good news is we
had enough demand for our product that
we were actually breaking the
infrastructure that we were built albeit
it was very bad infrastructure but we
did it anyways so well and just know
that that being bad is okay in the early
days because it's the first step to
building something amazing and my
favorite quote on this comes from the
legendary investor and founder of
LinkedIn Reid Hoffman and he said that
if you're not embarrassed by the first
version of your product you've launched
too late and I love this because it
really embodies the idea that done is
better than perfect
so let me show you guys what
embarrassing looked like for us when we
launched the first version of our
product so we could have gone out and
hired an engineering team and built out
this robust product of all the features
that we thought people wanted but
instead we hired an outsource
development team in India and we had
them slap together a landing page for us
and this is hideous it's this black
background with like 19 different fonts
and there's a couple shades of blue that
are clashing with each other it really
it makes me cringe looking at this today
but we had to get something out into the
world to see if people even cared what
we were doing and we took a lot of
solace in the fact that no one knows who
you are when you're launching and so
there's not that many people that you
can piss off or offend in the early days
you just want to get it out there hear
what people have to say and you can
always make it better but don't be
wrapped up in this idea that it needs to
be perfect before it gets out the door
because you don't even know what perfect
is yet so this is the version that we
ended up launching and this is actually
not where we are today
this was reformatted this was the very
first version that we launched back in
the day and all you could really do on
this site is
login you could enter your email address
create a password you could log in to
see how many people that you would
referred or you could refer your friends
through Facebook and we also had this
referral page and we went out and we got
a couple thousand tote bags printed and
we decided we were gonna send these bags
to anyone that could get three of their
friends to refer or get three of their
friends to come and enter their email
address on our website and this is the
type of stuff that's very inexpensive to
you but it goes a long way with
customers and potential customers so
with this very simple landing page on
this referral tool behind it we were
able to gather over 25,000 email
addresses in the first few months that
we could market to and this gave us more
customers than we could handle for over
a year so geez so we were two guys
starting women's fashion company we
worked in finance before we didn't have
a background in merchandising or
operations but we did know Excel and
PowerPoint like the back of our hand and
so instead of trying to go out and like
build all these things we didn't know
how to do and use tools that we didn't
know how to work we built everything in
Excel and PowerPoint so this is one of
the very first design sessions we did we
used to mock everything up in PowerPoint
and we'd send it to our offshore
development team and this is not ideal
is actually a horrible way to do it but
it got things done and it got our first
product out the door so all the
customers could do at the time was go on
the website and fill out a quick style
profile and it had things like their age
their style preferences their
measurements their location so we used
to download these in Excel make each tab
a customers name and put them into this
master excel workbook now at the end of
this we had like thousands of tabs in
this workbook and it took like 15
minutes to open this thing but it got us
where we needed to go and so over time
it's actually morphed into we started
tracking every single item that we sent
customers we would manually enter this
stuff and then we get feedback in the
customer service inbox and we put that
off to the side and if it sounds really
that's because it was we even tracked it
we even tracked every single shipment
that went out to customers so this
spreadsheet also had like thousands of
rows by the end and this is all to say
that you can do a lot with a little in
the early days so just think about what
you can do well and go out and build
with those tools and that skill set the
next the next important thing is that
you've got to get out and actually talk
to your customers so once you get your
product out into the world you have to
hear what people think so I always
encourage people to actually go meet
people collect phone numbers collect
email addresses give them a phone call
my co-founder and I were the customer
service for our business for the first
18 months or so and just being in the
flow every day talking to customers
hearing what they had to say was
incredibly helpful and it gave us a lot
of insights into how to make the service
better you also have to charge people
money a lot of people are willing to or
tell you what they're willing to pay for
something or they tell you oh yeah I
would use it this way or that way but
until their parting with their
hard-earned cash no one's gonna give you
an unbiased opinion so you've got to
charge for whatever you're putting out
there and the last thing is you've got
to question all of your assumptions you
have so for us when we started the
business we thought our demographic was
gonna be significantly younger turns out
it's actually a working professional
woman we thought that our customers were
gonna really like to get a curated
mystery box every time and our customers
actually want a lot more control over
the experience and we also figured that
because people were signing up for a
rental service they wouldn't actually
want to buy anything and we were
completely wrong on that luckily because
purchase is now a huge part of our
revenue so once you put your product out
there it built something and you've
talked to your customers you've got to
you've got to iterate and this is the
most important piece so you've got to
take all that feedback and build
meaningful improvements into your
product based on what your customers
tell you and I think we've been able to
do that so I want to give you guys a
quick glimpse into where we are today
luckily I no longer sit and fill out
spreadsheets all day and I'm
in charge of design which is great for
everyone we've got a massive
distribution center out in the Central
Valley
these are racks that I didn't build
myself which is why they're holding up
so well we've built our own inventory
management system from scratch we have
an amazing in-house development team
data scientists we built our own
warehouse management system as well it's
all cloud-based we send out thousands of
items daily moving us closer to our
mission of making fashion accessible for
everyone every day
so again I'm Brett oh geez I'm Brett I'm
the founder of the tote thank you guys
so much
I'm also horrible at working a little
clicker apparently apologize hi Brett
thanks so much for talking to us just
had a quick question about I'm getting
your products out quickly do you think
that gets in the way of building a
strong brand like if it's a crappy
product then it might like get in the
way of building a strong brand yeah so
it really depends what kind of product
you're launching if if you if you just
created that $700 juicer machine you
have to make sure your product is dialed
in from day one because you only get one
shot at really putting a huge consumer
product like that out into the market
and it's really expensive to go and get
something like that prototype and built
out and you can't just iterate I think a
lot of this is in the context of
software but for us it was kind of a mix
of software and physical goods and so we
just wanted to see what people thought
and if there was demand now it really
it's very specific to whatever product
you're building I think hi Brett I'm
Roxy hey hi so I have a very similar
model but the problem that I'm having is
to go to market strategy so can you
explain a little bit how you figure that
out when you first started because I'm
kind of in the same position sure yeah
so we we just talked to anyone that
would listen to us really we we started
asking a lot of people if they would be
interested in a service like this what
they thought of it we actually just
bought a bunch of clothing and sent it
to friends and colleagues like anyone
that would take a box and we got
feedback from them before we went out to
the market and then we started we sort
of buying some Google Adwords just to
drive people to our landing page and we
wanted to figure out what price point
people would be willing to pay so we put
them at prices in the ads and we drove
them to a landing page we also put a
checkout page up with varying
configurations of the box so today we
send three garments and two accessories
and we didn't just pick this out of thin
air we arrived at that after like
iterating on this quite a bit so there
was a lot that went into figuring it out
and then that landing page and the
referral thing that I showed helped us
get a ton of email addresses early on we
just gave away like some freebies and
because it was a gated experience we
were in like a private beta we used
exclusivity to our advantage and we
didn't we said you have to refer a
certain number of people to actually get
early access to the site so we use
exclusivity as a way to also like juice
our referrals how many people do you
think you actually reached before you
decided to go all-in you mean like how
many people did we talk to yes yeah
hundred everybody talked to like any any
women that we could find they would
listen to two guys and like a coffee
shop or you know the streets of San
Francisco people that were like crazy
dudes walking around and just talking
people but amazing yeah you have to do
we have to do so I don't know hundreds
thousands out of those yeah but don't
overthink it too much I think a lot of
people like again like you have to
charge money for your product early on
because until you're charging a lot of
people like oh I love that idea I hate
that idea but until you put it out there
it's hard to know thank you thank you
Brad that's all the time we have things
cool cheers guys thanks